yeah when I was a little kid I was
already pretty excited about science so
I'd like reading about it so a classic
experiments and physics others and I
think part of that was that my parents
were always supplying and with
interesting for the adventure
besides issues and then one fateful
thanksgiving an uncle from California
shut up who turned out to be a ham radio
operator this is long before on the
internet existed before people everybody
pure in some ways that people used to
talk to each other was a over can radio
you would build radio transmitters and
receivers and he put her antenna up on
the roof and one dinner with this guy I
was totally hooked so I went out got ham
license convinced my parents to let me
put an antenna on the road and have all
it's stuck in my radio area in the
basement so I played around with that
for a number of years and and then in
high school I found that I really
enjoying half in chemistry physics and
did a lot of work in those areas and
finally even had an opportunity after
junior year to go to serve little summer
camp technological program at
Northwestern University and Robin
Chicago State University my parents that
want to so they're really excited about
it and that was really a lot of fun and
so then as an undergrad I really was
already enough sort of combine your
breath
program one of the opportunities to do
bio chemistry research with a guy named
Mike check who runs a huge medical
program at us worcester now and so he
and I would talk every day about fat
cells which is the computer working and
just that that conversation made science
really good signing for me Mike I sit
down and say what kind of data did you
got yesterday are explained it to him
and he quietly sit there and think in
the next experiment that I reveal how
these particular fat cells were working
to generate heat for the animals so
called brown fat is like up it's like in
a fat pad behind the neck and rodents
use it it's like a generator of heat so
that was just a major experience I think
there was really catalyzing for me I
finished medical school and I wasn't
really sure what to do but I thought
okay I think I've got time to do a
little bit of medical training let me
see if I like that and I sort of liked
it but after the year and a half or so I
I got really fascinated in the idea at
that point in history of tumorigenesis
mediated by violence that was a sort of
dominant theme people there studying so
not a gene inside of a tumor virus could
make a normal cell turn into a holding
of cancer cell and so the next thing you
know instead of all the pediatric papers
piling up on my nightstand it was being
crushed under the weight of all these
papers about virus mediated malignant
cell transformation and so when I
finished residency I went to the Salk
Institute in California and work in a
just amazing environment I was just
very lucky with the people or it was a
dawn of the DNA cloning age who were
interested in climbing pieces of these
viruses that were so-called transforming
jeans a single gene that could make a
cell become employed itself and it was
just an amazing place because everybody
was treated the same whether you were
completely new to science at between a
molecular sciences I was for whether you
were in Francis Crick who was our
next-door neighbor over outside
co-discoverer the structure of DNA or
renato dulbecco you just want to know
well prize for figuring out how cells
are transformed by viruses were Bob
Holly who had figured out essentially
one aspect of how information is
transferred in the cell and got a Nobel
Prize for the network but all these guys
were just absolutely modest wonderful
people who are having to talk to you
about any problem that you that you have
on the plate and so it's just a
wonderful environment but at that ended
three years I thought team it looks like
it's possible to clone human genes all
of a sudden and you know my medical
training that involved conditions that
were terrible conditions where genes
were clearly involved I thought wow I
think I'm going to go back to New Haven
and try to solve one of these really
horrible inherited conditions so I
worked on enzyme deficiency that kills
kids on the second or third day of life
and they're more normally and then they
die of ammonia oxidation
and white typically and so we isolated
that Jane and develop a DNA diagnosis
and called for trouncing new therapies
for it and so that sort of brings me to
today story because subsequent to that I
went across the hall from where I didn't
doing work under the auspices that we
really find scientist me on the
Rosenberg and started my own lab and I
had a pretty good idea about what I
wanted to do in that lab and I'll tell
you a little bit about that but along
the way an accident occurred in the form
of an experiment we did and now I'm led
to a 20 years story that has been just
briefly referred to and I'll flush out
for you so title of my talk is
chaperonins that's what we've studied
for the 20 years or so molecular origami
machines and I can definitely tell you i
would have never predicted that we would
stumble into something like this but
that's what happened so i'm going to
spend just a couple slides to give you
background so what we're talking about
here is basic information transfer in
the cell so you know that DNA contains
all the information but blueprint for
life as we know and for all the the
things that make us what we are well at
the other end beyond that blueprint are
the effectors the things that actually
do the work that make us what they are
there is encoded by beginning and those
are called proteins and they have to be
in particular three-dimensional
architectures fold it up in order to do
the work so how do you get from
a two well this central information
transfer captain Holt sometimes called
the central dogma that would it was
worked out by many people in 15 60s 70s
80s running out to today they're a spin
speed study but in the simplest form the
DNA contains regions where there are
triplets of DNA there's a JCT is the
form certain designators to work with
the four bases and so when DNA does is
it gets copied by polymerase into what's
called our net or messenger are it has a
message from the DNA and it's an exact
blueprint so for example you can see
here that this blue line contains
essentially a copy of what is the upper
strand of this DNA okay so that's an RNA
copy and that RNA copy contains Triplets
of it AJC teen whatever a reporter that
in a particular order then encodes amino
acids so this is the transition from
nucleic acid to protein and that occurs
on a machine called the ribosome that I
won't really talk too much about but
Yale is famous for Robison's because we
have tom sites here who figured out the
x-ray structure of a good chunk of
neuroticism received a nobel prize for
that work several years ago but the
ribosome converts essentially that
information in this linear strand
plague acid bases to entice the triplets
and each triplet impose one amino acid
so they're totally differently here
indicate the sequence of amino acids is
being produced okay so that's like a
strand of spaghetti that leaves the
ribosome so as a strand of spaghetti it
has no 3d structure is really sort of
lacking the full information the
information comes after protein folding
clothes and that's really what we're
going to talk about today is how do you
get from a strand of spaghetti to folded
structure that carries out the cellular
function so that function could be
structural could be like your hair is
made of protein structure i'll show you
a microscopic level which is the second
or it could be an enzyme that carries
out of chemistry so in our bodies there
are tons of metabolic reactions going on
all the time they can't go on
spontaneously they have to be so called
catalyzed or sped up by the action
enzymes that can do this chemistry the
carry out a chemical reaction or
transporters molecules that help I or
other substances get into your cells
from outside okay what is the
architecture of approach I really should
explain that before we talk about
protein folding any detail so again
there's a string of amino acid building
blocks so it can be anywhere from maybe
10 amino acids to the thousands of amino
the structural proteins for example but
each block is any one of 20 different
amino acids so for each amino acid
position in the protein there's 20
different choices basically but the
codon or that triplet that's back there
at level the DNA and the RNA dictates
which amino acid gets put onto the
growing strength okay so with tends to
thousands of amino acids a typical
protein is about 200 to 600 amino acids
okay so that that that's a sort of
characteristic size protein so ending in
Dalton's for those who are comfortable
with it it would be anywhere committee
if he can kill a dog 50 to 60 kill the
Daltons okay so each protein has a
characteristic sequence of amino acids
and as a result of that it has a
characteristic three-dimensional folded
structure so so that structure can be
part of supporting the cell in some way
or it could be an enzyme that's floating
around and has an active site that
carries out a chemical reaction um so
the folded structure is the epitome of
the protein okay and so here's a really
simple protein made out of like a
Tinkertoy and so it has a seamless of
amino acids so these top guys are
strands and there's an arrow that
indicates which way the strand is
pointing and this is like an
antiparallel stranded one's one
direction on the top and it different
the bottom and then below that is what
you really call an alpha helix this is
sort of symbolic I'll show you what that
looks like it slide or so then see each
amino acid here is colored differently
and so and that's true I haven't really
colored leaving all acids in these
so-called loose that they would be rich
in an amino acid typically logical I see
which has essentially kind of sergeant
is the hydrogen cast and here is an
alpha helix with different amino acid
okay so that's just my own tiny
construct or what a program could look
like that now here are examples of real
so here is eamon Logan on the left so
that is the red blood cells are
chock-a-block full of hemoglobin and it
is an oxygen carrying molecule so these
red e groups are shown inside of all
these alpha kilo sees the form each of
the subunits by human book so therefore
subunits a hemoglobin molecule and each
of them is carrying an oxygen through
one of these in groups you can see the
oxygen in this particular image but
there's two so-called alga subunits into
so-called Bay this of you but they're
actually eerily similar to each other
okay here's a picture of hair composed
of keratin once again out the Gila sees
play a prominent role in this structure
they wander around each other to me to
make the gainer now here's a transporter
solve a structure solved by a good
friend of mine so years ago for which
even see the Nobel Prize so here you see
a potassium channel and you can see the
potassium
in this channel so this is called the
selectivity filter that specifically
recognizes potassium's and no other ions
and allows them to go through that
filter and here are these long real
estates outfit Ulysses they're sort of
the background structure of the channel
they're crossing membrane of the cell
which I haven't shown you here but then
they cross with a local the selectivity
filter now I've been talking about all
these alpha helical structures there are
lots of structures that are rich in
those beta strands that I showed you a
second ago so here's one of the protein
that's like that transthyretin it
carries thyroid hormone in on blood and
it has a whole bunch of central beta
sheets and it binds hormone if I
remember correctly at either end here
goodbye at least two molecules of the
flanks of the subunits okay the question
we really wanted to come to was how do
proteins for so if they start out as
like a strand of amino acids like a
piece of spaghetti produced at the
ribosome how do they reach their
three-dimensional structure well i'm
going to show you probably the single
most important experiment that's ever
been done in protein folding carried out
by man named christian and pizza the
late 1950s he received a nobel prize for
this work in 1972 so what he showed was
then that amino acid sequence in the
protein contains all of the information
that's necessary for the protein to be
able to fold into its three-dimensional
structure so how do these potty prove
this well first he had the idea I want
to ask this question if I take a
purified protein and I completely unfold
it by putting it into some
chemical teenagers that make it come
apart and go back to being a strand of
spaghetti can it find its way back to
the folded form all by itself is there
enough information in the strand of
spaghetti to make the protein fold into
its active form so he took this enzyme
home ribonuclease so we were talking
about RNA a few slides ago this is a
small enzyme that actually makes our
name digests it just cuts it into little
pieces so it's easy to assay so he took
this protein it has some bonds called
disulfide not where to sobres come
together and make a covalent bond and he
broke it apart he'd be completely
unfolded the protein by using the
chemical to nature called yuliya and he
used what's called were inducted that
brings these disulfide bonds and now he
had essentially just a thesis godaddy a
cat so here's ribonuclease spaghetti in
this middle panel here then he said okay
I'm going to take away that urea and
number kept to ethanol these things that
are making spaghetti and so put him in a
dialysis back so dialysis bag is a place
where your protein sits on the inside
and the ions and small molecules just on
a little tiny holes in the sullivan hall
as it were out into a big welcome and so
as he did that remarkably the revenue
face group folded and became
enzymatically
so this is a absolutely astonishing
result and actually when I was an
undergrad at Brown in 1972 when he won
the prize I never heard about this
experiment but it was in the newspapers
on the front page and everybody in our
fats on lemon oh my god that is
unbelievable we have to see what
proteins we have in the lab let's see if
we can do that experiment and so for
just days of days are just talking about
it's unbelievable experiments fails so I
never thought I would ever have anything
to do with anything that view is just
spectacular making you do this so um let
me can do a little more background and
now I'll tell you about the experiments
that we've gone so there are conditions
that you can subject and already folded
protein to that make it become miss
Holden and aggregate so remember I said
there's a three dimensional full that's
the native state you can make the
protein lead that native state by
heating it up so a good example is an
egg so it when you look at the wife of
an egg it's clear you break the egg into
the pan and here's the major protein
that's in that white part of that gets
called about human and you can see it
has a very complicated fold a lot of
beta strands in its of alpha helix and
it's very order and its structural and
what happens when you heat it I can't
show you because we don't know the
structure but it becomes aggregate
becomes a big mess everything is
unfolded and sticking to everything else
between molecules so this oval human on
the Left would be stuck to another three
or four in all of them an unfolding
spaghetti like state and so that's
called aggregation so the white of an
egg is really an aggregate of
principal protein in that aggregate is
Oh Bellevue okay so he is a stress it
causes proteins to become unfolded miss
folded and aggravated and the same thing
happens inside cells so you took a
bacterial cell so now we're looking a
little electron micrograph here and you
heat shot the cell so that it was
growing at 25 degrees or 30 degrees
centigrade like room temperature let's
say and now you take it up to like our
body temperature or something like that
that's a heat shock for that cell and
here are the aggregates that always go
to the terminal end of the cell so this
is all sorts of aggregated protein of
that bacterial sup it's not a single
protein like ovalbumin it's a lot of
different proteins all gone together in
a Miss folded and inactive State so
that's an aggregate and the business of
bacterium tries to stay alive by putting
this stuff out to the end of the sub
here's where its DNA is it keeps it away
from its nuclear where its DNA is okay
so what about Miss holding an
aggregation it's bad for the cell in two
major ways why is proteins that have to
get to a functional
I maintain a functional form lose it
because they've become unfolded they no
longer have that three-dimensional
structure that's active they're just
aggregated and dysfunctional okay and
aggregates can be toxic so now we're
talking about a medical side of this so
people who have sickle cell anemia have
a hemoglobin which you saw that in
living color few slides ago they have a
hemoglobin that has a mutation in it
that causes the globin chains to miss
old and aggregate inside the red cells
and they make really sharp engines that
actually cause the red cells to break
and so that's why it's an anemia is
because all those red cells are gone
they're constantly breaking okay the
second example is in Alzheimer's disease
a neurodegenerative condition that
unfortunately people beyond for example
80 years of age I'm almost the fifty
percent chance of having there are
aggregates that form inside the brain
and they're toxic to it in ways that we
don't employee understand at this point
they're typically outside of cells
between neurons that they are toxic to
the central nervous system well there's
even worse news actually to tell you and
that is that miss folding and
aggregation are going on all the time in
normal cells in you and me all the time
so a good percentage of all the proteins
that we make our Miss folding and
aggregating all the time so it's not
like the anthems an experiment where all
the ribonuclease molecules went nicely
down the ski slope to the lodge that was
the native state the fully folded active
structure in the case of the cell many
proteins while they're getting made get
lost on their way down the ski slope so
they get into a local minima
so you as I do all the time when I go
skiing ever all my kids laugh at me they
said dad you're stuck do we have them
come and pull you out of there so the
protein can't get down the slope is
stuck in a local area a local energetic
minimum where it's miss folded and
that's where it's at risk for aggregate
and so the idea is does Mother Nature
have a defense against us is there a way
to prevent this gold and aggregation and
the answer is yes mother Nature doesn't
leave anything to chance how was this
discovered and how does it work how does
a machinery that prevents proteins from
Miss folding in the cell actually work
okay so now i'm just a little background
and then we're coming up to some of
their own work so in the 1970s that i
just told you about heat stress and what
it does to an egg for example in the
1970s people were heating up cells and
observing that there there are
specialized proteins inside the cell
then become very abundant under heat
shock conditions and these were called
heat shock proteins so here you see a
cell in normal temperature and now it's
at it at a hijab temperature all these
are identical Wayne's more or less but
here you see that there are two size
proteins king shock protein 90 which is
a 90,000 volume protein called your p 95
and heat shock proteins 70 of 70,000
Dalton's called a 76 and their heat
shock proteins that are induced when the
fruit when themselves exposed to a
stress like he
shop and here's a small in shock protein
that's smaller ones burger on this so
called electrophoresis job okay well
people saw that there were these heat
shock proteins that they said well you
know they obviously correlate with
protecting the cell but how do they work
do they affect Lucas metabolism do they
protect DNA and RNA under heat shock
conditions do they protect membranes
what do they do and so nobody had any
really good idea about this they're it a
lot of different hypotheses and then
working in the end um in England Hugh
Pelham in nineteen eighty-four had a
really major suggestion that heat shock
proteins are actually protecting other
proteins during heat stress so in other
words the heat shock protein is
preventing the white of the egg from
going from clear to white it's actually
able to maintain it in a clear state and
so at the cellular level what he did was
to overexpress hsp70 and he noticed that
he chocked cells the nucleus and heat
shock cells started to look funny under
heat shock conditions but if you
overexpress hsp70 it was normal the
nucleus seemed to be normal in recover
very rapidly from the heat shock and
went on to function normally and so here
was his molecular model based on some
experiments that I won't review that
were really brilliantly conceived so
here is an hsp70 purpose we're now
talking about protein itself a
specialized protein that is molecular
crowbar so the idea is HSP seven
binds to incipient ly aggregating
proteins these are two proteins that
shouldn't stick together under normal
conditions than on their heat stress
they're starting to stick to each other
and what happens is when hsp70 lines to
these guys it through the offices of
burning setp hydrolyzing the energy
currency ATP to ADP in there's a probar
action it actually separates these two
proteins from each other and the idea is
that hsp70 would cycle back and forth so
these are the first intuitions about how
what we call chaperones work so a lot of
people in your room don't know what a
molecular chaperone is but the idea is
in the Victorian era in the late 1800s
when you went on out on a date with
somebody of the opposite sex you always
had to go out with a chaperone who would
keep the two of you from having to
elicit interactions with each other
during your date okay and that's what
these guys are doing they're preventing
proteins from having illicit
interactions that's the idea of
molecular chaperones to prevent those
interactions that we call aggregation of
occurrence by actually binding to a
protein and preventing it from
aggregating okay so now we come to Yale
so it's 1987 so this is some years after
Pelham's initial experiment and people
are in agreement across the field that
under heat shock conditions there these
proteins induce they seem to prevent
agar
asian so we're working in against system
symbol baker's yeast you have lots of
cells in our culture you can and they
have only one copy of every gene so it
makes it easier than working with two
copies is we all have so you can work
with mutant yeast that were lots of
things hemant so where's late one night
in the lab while we're studying a system
that I'll describe in just a second and
we say hot under normal conditions do
you thinking in molecular chaperones not
just stressful conditions with normal
conditions and is there such a thing as
a protein folding machine in other words
it sees the newly made piece of
spaghetti and it actually folds a
spaghetti into that native
three-dimensional proper structure
that's happened no no okay so here's the
system we were working on at that point
so we were studying how proteins that
are that make up mitochondria actually
get to mitochondria so let me just go
slow for a second so most of the
proteins of mitochondria are actually
encoded in the nucleus in our DNA the
mitochondria themselves have a little
snippet of DNA to make a few films but
most of the proteins are actually
encoded by the nucleus and so they're
actually made on ribosomes we talked
about translation on ribosomes of Thomas
lights is beautiful world and so the
proteins are made on ribosomes that they
have a little ticket a little signal at
the front end that says taking to
mitochondria I'm not going to live in
the cytosol and so this signal gets
recognized by receptor system in the
mitochondrial membranes and then the
protein goes into mitochondria so it's a
zip code as it were okay now we knew
from some experiments that
carried out the preceding year that for
proteins to actually pass through the
mitochondrial membranes they have to be
completely unfolded so they have to be a
strand of spaghetti to go through the
mitochondrial membrane so it's just like
coming off the ribosome spaghetti or you
can't go through the membrane okay now
what happens on the other side of the
membranes so this is what everybody
believed after the entrance an
experiment that proteins go through the
membranes and now they hold
spontaneously and now you have two
biological function whatever it is and
so the what we suggested was ha could
there be a machine on the other side of
the mitochondrial membranes that
actually assists or mediates the folding
and without it nothing folds correctly
okay if that's true that if we have a
mutation that affects that machine and
nothing will fold correctly proteins
will be imported into the mitochondria
and then they'll just be biologically
dead and they'll probably aggregate and
that is exactly what we found within a
couple weeks of having this idea so I
think that the take home is no idea is
ridiculous until you test it we kept
testing us over and over again and a lot
of different proteins and counted aha
we've actually found a negative effects
the folding of newly imported proteins
reaching so now this is a diagram at the
inside
my contract so here are proteins that we
test it I won't go through them this is
our original reporter protein here are
some other ones that all of them went
into the organelles and then they failed
to pull and we could rescue the cells
the cells die immediately within 45
minutes they were dead so we did rescue
the cells with a gene that encoded what
was what we call a heat shock protein of
sixty thousand dollars hsp60 for sure so
this is a protein than somebody else has
observed a man named Richard hauber can
observe the year ahead of time was a
mildly he'd inducible protein inside
mitochondria been a very abundant
protein and he also had done electron
microscopy on it and shown that it was a
ring assembly and so this ring structure
we now could relate to the folding of
proteins entering mitochondria okay
here's just some of the principles of
that work Ming Chang was my first
graduate student at Yale she was the
young physician he came from Taiwan and
so she pulled up this mutant I said
making us incredible we don't believe it
and nobody else believed us I mean
you're contravening something that's
been around for 25 30 years now namely
that proteins old spontaneously in
living cells and showing that they don't
and here is Kirsten Greg who joined
shortly after and she is responsible for
what I'm going to show you in a few
minutes of the first x-ray structure one
of these machines and here is over
startled and his wife bondage it who
contributed considerably to the
biochemistry of the experiment that I
showed you because we had a hard time
believing our own results we were afraid
apartment results and we went to them
were called by one of the major
mitochondrial labs in the world and
Munich of which or ish was one of the
senior members work at there being a
wall turnover who was the big block over
Claus and an Orisha knew what we were
doing he said I mean what we want to
help you guys work this out we have a
hard time believing this also but let's
do some more biochemistry and so our
groups work together for several years
before we find they published on this
when we were absolutely sure that it was
clear that this was a folding machine
inside mitochondria ok so now I'm going
to fast forward a little bit so it turns
out that here is the component that we
study called heat shock protein 60 in
mitochondria well you know mitochondria
in evolution are descended essentially
from events that relate to one bacterial
cell eating another cell you know one of
the cells became
inside the other one so bacteria turned
out how irrelevant hsp60 called grow yo
bro just means growth eat meant a phage
protein that is very important requires
this machine in order to make page
articles this is a some historical
significance but I won't dwell on and l
is for large as a larger stuff in it and
then the third leg of this triangle was
inside plants there are small organelles
clone for class that are involved with
co 2 fixation as you know and there
there was another protein that was
another double drain assembly that was
shown to be involved with assembly of
the co2 fixing has oncologist ok so
these are three shepherds in the
evolutionarily related group and then
Jonathan Trent who was a postdoc in my
group discovered a second family of
these relating a arca bacterial that's
another Kingdom of life in addition to
back to lea ann arbor bacterial double
ring to protein folding inside of our
bacteria and then remarkably he found a
relationship to one of these things
inside of our own cells in the cytosol
called T complex HoloNet
or chaperonin containing polypeptide one
as you can see this double ring assembly
has different subcommittee okay they're
all of these carried out protein folding
just like hsp60 does okay so how do any
of these things work so the next thing
that was done was an experiment carried
out by George warmer and his co-workers
at can they be constituted a folding
reaction by one of these ring assemblies
in a tested in a two-step reaction so in
the first step they took bacterial bro
elk and they took a protein that was of
Rubisco one of the most abundant enzymes
in the biosphere unfolded it in your
rear just like understood in the
original anthems of experiment and said
what happens when I incubate this
unfolded protein with this grow yell
double ring what happens is you get a
what's called a stoichiometric 121
complex of the unfolded protein bound to
this double ring inside the central hole
of the ring then in a second step they
added a little lid structure that shares
the coding region with grow Al and
bacteria called bro e small growing s
and so all of these are seven membered
rings so there's seven of these in each
bring here and this is a seven member
big one big one contacts with this ring
and so when you add grow vs and
magnesium ATP voila over the space of a
couple minutes native Rubisco fully
folded and correctly folded is released
from this system so this is the whole
folding reaction but how does it work
what I mean what goes on I mean is it
some sort of magic or what goes on
what's this binding reaction all about
if you don't have growing L here this
protein will just aggregate and that's
true for most broken so we're just
aggregate so grow yells somehow captures
them and prevents them from Miss folding
they're holding a state where they're
not biologically active yet that they're
stabilized against aggregation and now
in the second step of this reaction
bromius finds as a lid over this
polypeptide bound ring and now the
protein is folded okay so how does a
machine 1 by 1991 there were about 20
different models forgot my book almost
as many different models as there were
investigators weren't honest so that's
when an accident happened where I got to
meet a Paul sigler who had just come to
Yale from the University of Chicago and
was working over and that gives building
right across the way from where we are
here and so Paul and just solved a major
structure of DNA binding protein bound
DNA and here he is with key members of
his team aundrea amia and it's fishnet
Kalinowski and so I this was an asset
the School of Medicine said you have to
go over and talk to Paul sigler about an
administrative matter just take care of
it you got to just don't do it so I'm
walking to similars office they says
this is ridiculous we don't have to talk
about this administrative nonsense it's
taken care of forget about it it's just
done that I want to talk about what you
guys are doing with these ring
assemblies you're never going to figure
out how they work unless you get a
crystal structure at high resolution of
this machine then you'll be able to
generate a model for how it really works
and so he drags fish back into the room
spish that looks at how big this thing
is he says I'm sorry but there's no
computing on earth right now that can
handle this kind of problem but I'm not
worried because it's going to take you
guys a couple of years to generate a
good crystal this molecule and by then
we'll have computers that can handle
this so okay he was right it took us
several years to crystallize this we
tried a lot of things I won't detail
that but eventually first and brave my
student that he saw a picture of pulled
this beautiful crystal out of a drop she
had like a wall of trades each one with
like 50 wells or 48 wells and with a
crystallization offer and throw this
wall of trays she found this drop with
this beautiful crystal in it and we took
that and diffracted that in x-rays and
spish act was he was right he was ready
with computing and with his own program
for how to solve the structure of this
complicated
machine and so here you see it in the
flush and high resolution the determined
model from the x-ray structure and so
grow L is essentially proposed of two
back-to-back rings and so each ring has
seven subunits that each subunit is
folded into three different domains so
never even bogen have four subunits you
can hear their these are guns within a
subunit and we're so good at seven some
units per ring and each subunit has
green onions so these equatorial domains
make the waistline of this machine and
they're the base that holds the machine
together and the intermediate domain is
a hinge and the apical domains are
attached at the end of that terminal
ends of their mediadrawings so these
typical domains are the business end of
their machine because they're inside
aspect as I'll show you in just a second
is a hydrophobic surface a greasy
surface that can specifically recognize
proteins that are miss folded it has no
affinity for normal folded protein even
though it might float into the hole and
float back out it just seems misfolded
proteins and binds them and so on here
what's the scale your maybe a question
that a few people have so I just want to
diverge for one second how big is a girl
double ring okay here's a bacterial cell
in the transmission electron microscope
it's magnified 20 thousand times so
normally you can only see a bacterial
cell and roughly 40 x
vacation in a regular microscope in the
electron microscope you can you get good
magnification here is what a girl will
look like inside this cell if it were
magnified ten times over normal so if
you drop the size of this by tenfold you
no longer could see it but yet there are
thousands of growing L molecules
floating around inside a bacterial cell
ready to find the full proteins they're
almost as abundant as the ribosomes off
of which proteins are made ok here is
the poly peptide binding surface of a
growing old man so if you were standing
in the top right of the double ring and
looking at the back wall this is what
you would see you would see all these
residues and I'll just say that these
amino acids have a side chain that is
greasy in his hydrophobic and they're
pointing directly into the cavity of the
ring so they're there to bind a Miss
rodent or not need a colleague had time
and captured it so some years later we
were able to actually see a protein
that's unfolded all it's bound to grow
up so here's that protein called mailing
dehydrogenase it's an enzyme and here's
its subunit captured by three of those
so-called apical domains of gravida and
so here you see the blue is the mdh
right in the middle of the county
touching three or four of these apical
domains so they're binding it through
these hydrophobic interactions now let
me emphasize this hydrophobicity because
this is that this is the principal to
all molecular chaperones that I'm
talking about ring assemblies but there
are other types of chaperones and have
different geometries for binding miss
golden or
native proteins so in a normal folded
protein all the greasy stuff all those
blue scenes and I solutions and greasy
side chains are buried to the inside of
the protein they make a hydrophobic form
to the protein so hydrophobic core is a
water hating kind of thing it wants to
bury itself and stay away from water
it's energetically unfavorable for that
stuff to be exposed to water but under
conditions of stress are in the cell
when a protein is in the process of
folding that hydrophobic core can become
exposed at the surface of a protein and
now these greasy services like in the
egg under heat stick together and you
get aggravation and so that's a
dysfunctional protein that could lead to
disease sown Alzheimer's disease or
Parkinson's disease their characteristic
proteins that aggregate and that some of
them do that through a hundred phobic or
so what's the idea of the chaperonin it
has its own hydrophobic binding surface
surrounding the protein and that
prevents the protein from aggregate
here's a here's the proteins that
supposed hydrophobic surfaces will the
chaperonin it has its own hydrophobic
surfaces is seven around a ring and that
just binds the polypeptide and occupies
those services so that they can't go on
to aggregate okay now I want to talk
about folding because the second part of
that reaction is you remember from the
Georgia
former experiment is the part where you
add ATP and that lid structure and now
the protein actually folds and is then
released from the machine okay so Helen
stabled was key to this work so she is
the collaborator cars this is a rare
sunny day in London where she's sitting
out her backyard in the garden reading
something interesting here hope so when
we first looked at the growing L
structure and imposed on it a even a
folded protein of one of our favorite
proteins to work on home rhodanese the
protein rammed into the apical domains
there there's a terrible problem here
the protein really can't fit in the open
cavity of a ring even in this fully
folded state so how could it fold in
them but then Helen changed our thinking
on the time scale of a month or two when
she showed us these photos so these are
electron microscopic images of growing L
here you see one ring on top here's the
lower ring and this ring on top has that
lid that little lid structure called
grow yes bound to it and what what
happened now there's a big space
underneath grow yes in the grow yo
cavity suddenly we're thinking well a
protein might be able to fit in there
and maybe even fold in there in a
sequestered environment underneath grow
yes and so um Jonathan Weissman son of
Sherman was
genetics here who was a postdoc in my
lab at that point is now famous
investigator in UC San Francisco doing
beautiful work in a whole variety of
areas but when he was a postdoc he
carried out this very nice experiment
that made it clear that a protein could
be housed inside of a ring underneath
grow yes so what he did was what we call
an order of addition experiment he added
the non-native protein first so here's
10 th ER he could infuse rooney's or
whatever you wanted to use and advice to
ring it's only one girl ring at a time
they don't want to vote at the same time
okay then he has the lid structure
called grow yes so the lid comes on
randomly and either comes on to the same
ring as as this polypeptide Lord comes
on to the opposite ring and now he can
interrogate which ring it actually came
onto by adding what a protease called
proteinase k so if it's open if there's
an open ring as in this case opposite
that occupied by girl yes the protein is
completely digested away if on the other
hand the polypeptide is in the same ring
that growing a spine suit is completely
protected from the protease so that
means that the protein can be housed in
this chamber inside of this machine so
those involved in that space so Wayne
Fenton in my group I think when he was
doing the demonstration out here for an
hour or two he looks like Santa Claus so
to recognize
he may have been demonstrated the anti
aggregation properties of grow real for
you in a test two so what he did is he
took a protein he deluded it straight
into buffer it aggregated like crazy and
you can see a cloudy solution just like
that egg and then he diluted a protein
into a mixture with roel and the protein
solution stayed completely clear because
grow yell bound that protein and
preventive from aggregated okay so he
did this key experiment related to
folding he either started with what we
call a trans complex where grow yes is
bound to wandering and polypeptide to
the opposite ring or he made a cyst
complex where the polypeptide is
underneath grow yes inside of a growing
L ring and then he had an ATP and asked
what happened which one of these was
after it turned out that this was the
one that was acted this was the folding
active version of growing up a
polypeptide is housed underneath this
lid and it's released into the chamber
and it not folds in isolation where
nothing can interfere with it and then
at the end of that it's released into
free solution and in the case of OTC the
subunits assembled box spontaneously to
make the active form of the enzyme okay
so now we wanted to ask a further
question can a protein not only start
building in that chamber could go all
the way to the Holden active form inside
that chamber so the problem is that
normally the lid grow yes binds and
releases from grow al roughly every 10
seconds so it's cycles with ATP binding
houses in a double brain contents but in
a single rate context the nucleotide
cycle is water so I without detailing
this I just want to say they do form a
stable grow yes Bell single ring and so
we made that the lid won't come off it's
stuck in this ATP state and the protein
could in principle fold in that chamber
all the way to the natives day so the
experiment was to start with the single
ring buying the proteins just shown as
the line moves as we don't have a
structure for a piece of spaghetti fine
road knees to that rig then add grow yes
in ATP and make this folding chamber
okay so this is a stable large assembly
about 400,000 Dalton's quite large and
separable in what we call gel filtration
columns and so we asked okay where is
the roomies activity after this protein
is refolded can refold inside of this
chamber and we actually fraction ate the
whole chamber and show that the activity
goes with the chamber okay so here on
the top has just shown the recovery of
Grogan's activity only had girl yes na
TV the recovery rate is the same as a
normal bro al double ring and the same
occurs at a single ring and been in the
bottom gear what we've actually done at
each time point we've separated in this
column the 400 KD complete complex and
said okay is there any activity
associated with it and the answer is yes
the kinetics of refolding is exactly the
same
passing the whole reaction mixture so
that says that folding inside of this
chamber goes all the way to the folded
enzymatically active form and that ends
on his active while it's spinning around
inside this chamber so the chamber
supports holding to the native state
okay so what does the holding chamber
actually look like so in further x-ray
studies with postdoc and popsicles lab
particular genre jus was the major
Hooper here we produce crystals of grow
yes bound to growing up and so what you
see is this Romeo want ring looks like
just a standard unoccupied rule right
but this one that has grow yes bound to
it is undergone major changes in
conformation and here's what's happened
is best thought about it if you were
looking at an excavator so an excavator
has an equatorial domain that has the
engine an ATP in it and generates energy
and then there are two hinge structures
here that are like the intermediate
domain of grow L here so things can
happen around the hinges and here's the
working part that apical domains as that
were so here's that hydrophobic service
so here's what happens in reality you
start with unlike ended growing else of
the subject of this color fit has been
color and these two Gila sees H and I
are the poly peptide binding greasy
surface when grow yes binds as
illustrated here here you see the top
hat on top of the growing
already now the whole subunit and that
bull ring of the Machine undergoes this
huge conformational change that
symbolized down here the apical domains
elevated 60 degrees and then go 90
degrees clockwise so all that
hydrophobic surface that was involved
originally with binding of polypeptide
is facing us out of the war and there's
a completely new lining to the cavity
that is now as I'll show you in the next
slide is hydrophilic and character is
water loving it's electrostatic it's not
hydrophobic it's just the opposite so
here's here's the chamber that's formed
you can see bro yes found out top here
here's this little chamber about 70
angstroms and width and height and a
polypeptide told in isolation in this
space where it simply cannot aggregate
with anything else is in solitary
confinement here's what the wall
character did all this yellow was the
original hydrophobicity of an open ring
that's all been converted to hydrophilic
electrostatic character shown by all
this blue so that so all of the all of
this hydrophobicity has now moved
sideways to make contacts between the
subunits in the wall and the actual
cavity lining is completely changed to
autofill character and that would favor
that the polypeptide has to bury his own
hydrophobic surface it's been ejected
from the
cavity wall into this space where it
starts to hold on its own according to
Hampton sins principles it's simply
following its way down the ski slope
without the chance of aggregating to
anything else because there's nothing
else in here okay so I'm going to finish
now so it's ATP binding and hydrolysis
actually that drives this reaction
cycles so I've showed you various states
and the way the Machine goes between
those states is by using ATP as a
trigger as it were an ATP hydrolysis as
as a second type of tripping so here is
the activation of folding that occurs
when 7 8 eps bind to this particular
ring and through work of em on Horovitz
at the western institute in israel
relative but were very close friends of
tennis buddies it's been shown that this
ATP binds cooperatively so when one ATP
binds that favors thats it's more going
to bind in all the sites of that ring
will be full of ATP but with respect in
the opposite ring there's anti
cooperativity this ring is completely
unoccupied and disfavored to bind any
nucleotide when ATP is bound to this top
right okay so ATP binding moves this
ring in such a way that polypeptide can
bind an ordered way followed by grow yes
and now you have objections of the
polypeptide
folding chamber so this is the business
end of this reaction i'm going to show
you a movie of it in just a second that
takes about ten three runs for about 10
seconds and the Machine really doesn't
care whether a polypeptide is there or
not it can run on infinite cycle and as
long as there's a TV there okay at the
end of eight of ten seconds KTP
hydrolyzes to make a DP and now that
Gates entry of everything into the
opposite ring so MTP gets there probably
peptide gets there and then grow yes yes
there and now that ring becomes folding
active then at the same time that ATP
and polypeptide bind here they send what
we call an owl scared signal from from
this ring to this ring that is mean
check shun notice it says goodbye grow
es goodbye polypeptide goodbye ADP and
they all leave and go out into solution
now you're going to look down the barrel
of the rainy and you see all this yellow
service so that is the hydrophobic
bonding surface right here in the center
okay and you're now going to see the
ring from the side and the first thing
that happens is ATP binds in the seven
sites of the rain and now you see the
apical domains they're opening and going
counterclockwise at the same time this
is a protein that we
unfolded it becomes about two
hydrophobic sicknesses and now growing s
comes in now you see it huge that huge
rigid body movement elevation
counterclockwise twist and the
polypeptide is released into the county
so it has ten seconds unfolding that go
on roughly at the end of which ATP
hydrolysis occurs fierce free phosphate
coming out and now ATP can enter the
opposite way and that's the injection
notice so things are going to start to
leave this ring and simultaneously
additional ligands bind to this ring so
now it becomes folding active and you'll
see the blue blinking light which we
believe is just following ad vincent's
principles polypeptides injected into
that cavity and it finds its way down
the energy landscape okay so that was a
slow motion now this is what the
reaction is like in real time so you'll
see that a rate spends almost all this
time in the folding active state and
then the transition between the two
rings is only about a second or so so
all hell breaks loose is going to happen
like it okay so you so you can see
things leave one ring then come on the
other break so this so the machine
spends most of its time in a folding
active state so the duty cycle the
machine is greater than like ninety
percent of the time so growing all is
very active all the time the transitions
are very fast okay so let's see how
often two more volunteers
so let me just a college a few people so
many Irish were crucial to the early
discovery work a lot of people and
participated in structural work but
Kirsten grew the amazing crystals that
were just magical spish I'd solved that
initial structure shall we growing a
structure Helen r.e.m experiments Paul
passed away a year 2000 we really missed
him he had an idea every 20 seconds I
mean he was a he was called a human
dynamo and he was eulogized by really
one of the greatest crystallographers of
all time and ask for roots on mechanism
a whole group of people including Wayne
who was here earlier this morning that
participated in working out the dance of
our reaction cycle on the stated more
recently will work on ALS which has a
Miss folding a component to several
versions of ALS using a mouse model
we're hopeful that maybe we'll be able
to come up with something for that so I
thank you very much for your attention
I'd be happy to answer any questions
either about the science or about you
know what life is like doing sighs so
thanks so much